hey guys I'm on my way to a stand up to
cancer event and they're doing this live
Telestream live telecast but also a live
stream I guess technically if it's live
it's still a live stream so I'm sure
some of you guys have seen this on
television but we're also doing a big
social media component so I'm heading
there I'm meeting Joey Graceffa I'm not
sure who else is gonna be there so it'll
be kind of a fun surprise we're gonna be
doing their Facebook live stream and
interacting with you guys and I'm not
really sure all of what's gonna happen
but that's where it gets fun never
knowing what's gonna happen so let's go
get in the car and head to the event I
need my bag in my phone bag info we made
it and I found Daniel and Joey and we're
about to walk the red carpet and then
headed to the event we just signed the
wallet
standing up hard
Perrine rasoi
[Music]
they're on our way to social media
Joey's going to be doing a live stream
and try
we get
I don't know but it's really orange in
here yeah I feel like I'm in middle
school dance
[Music]
it's not a real bar there mocktails to
your hand is amazing so great so bye
boys you guys having to drink no we're
just blocking the bar so no we can get
the mocktail
so really we're guarding your you're not
actually allowed to drink guardians of
d'amato
okay well there's lots of different
stations there's the phone station over
here I definitely tweet bombs there Jim
so I've been obsessed with these chairs
it's like my dream chair and I love it
so much I think I would like to see
[Music]
our hands left it for the show I feel
like it went really really quickly so
thanks everyone who donated and watch
the livestream somebody's somebody's got
a little baby a little bun in the oven
okay
now I'm off to go play Monopoly that is
my favorite board game ever really yeah
we're gonna be playing at Super Mario
monopoly a monopoly yes
Wow you're invited you can come really
yeah okay okay okay okay so I was
editing this video and it was it was
kind of strange to watch back because
none of the actual event we really
showed in this vlog and I was kind of
just watching I was like wow it looks
like we're all having so much fun at
like this event to raise money for
cancer which was kind of the whole point
is to sort of have a good time and
interact with you guys but as this all
was going on I feel like the whole
reason sort of got lost on a lot of us
because every single person I feel like
that's watching this video has been
touched by this disease this awful thing
that takes people's lives way too early
I don't even know I just wanted to kind
of end this video because it just sort
of ended on the high notes and even
though it was an event to raise money
and many of you guys watch too many of
you guys donated many of you called in
and told your stories I think it's
something good has touched everyone and
it's a very serious issue and so I don't
you guys like watch this video and be
like why are you guys all like at this
event having a good time I don't know
how to really explain it but I don't
really like to talk about it I mean I
think it's something that a lot of
people maybe should talk about
I've lost family to cancer I've lost
close friends to cancer and it's just an
awful awful awful thing that no one
should ever have to experience and
unfortunately they do and I'm sure many
of you may be going through a lot right
now with said disease or know people
that have or have in the past but I just
wanted to send you guys a little message
of support and hope that hopefully one
day there will be an actual cure and
sometimes unfortunately it's the cure
that ends up killing a lot of people
because it's it's such a harsh treatment
it's terrible it's just so unfair and so
awful
and I just wanted you guys to know that
I love you and I care about you and that
I appreciate all of the support that
people put into this event and there's
so many amazing fundraisers and so many
people around the world that are trying
to find a cure to this disease
that's all I just really wanted to kind
of put an end to this video and I don't
even know if I'm doing a justice but
that's all I hope you guys are having a
wonderful day I love you and just know
that if you're going through this have
gone through this it's you guys aren't
alone there's people out there who are
going through the same exact thing and I
encourage you to talk to people find
people online who are going through the
same things maybe you can find a friend
in the comments you never know I love
you guys and also get care
[Music]
soda